ce médecin est démissionnaire comme 20
autres de ses collègues il répond à
l'appel lancé par leurs homologues des
hôpitaux métropole l'hôpital public
français va mal très mal ce n'est plus
un secret sa dégradation va crescendo
en guise de contestation il ne
démissionne non pas de leurs postes de
médecins mais de leurs tâches
administratives
en tant que chef de service
l'organisation de nos hôpitaux publics
aujourd'hui est arrivé au bout de ce
qu'elle pouvait offrir et que nous
sommes plus en mesure aujourd'hui de
nous projeter dans le système tel qu'il
est pour continuer à soigner dignement
des patients dans ce service plutôt
sensible de l'hôpital mango ville st le
personnel est peu nombreux pour la prise
en charge des dix-huit patients qui sont
actuellement hospitalisées les efforts
financiers consentis par le ministère
sont insuffisants pour pallier les
carences
le chum présente un déficit de près de
120 millions d'euros
les perspectives d'avenir sont nuls on a
besoin de fauteuils roulants
il faut savoir que notre part de
fauteuils roulants compte environ une
vingtaine de fauteuil roulant sur
laquelle on a cinq fauteuils fonctionnel
donc nous sommes dans des discussions
avec la direction nous avons l'oreille
de notre direction qui nous dit qu'il
fait le nécessaire et sauf que le
problème est que les moyens à la hauteur
de l'enjeu et les organisations de soins
ne nous permettent pas de répondre tout
de suite nous sommes dans des
discussions depuis plusieurs mois nous
avons envie de développer des filières
de soins un accueil adapté aux besoins
sauf que le système est incapable de
nous répondre aujourd'hui
dans un courrier adressé agnès buzyn
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé
chef de service de paul ii département
élus de la commission médicale
d'établissement du chum réclame un plan
avec un volet national et un volet
régional plan que les praticiens
démissionnaire de martinique ou bien
détaillé en fonction de leurs besoins et
spécificités
cette démission des médecins ne
devraient pas perturber les ateliers
directement aux soins des patients